so we're getting our first sort of
serious signal that this could be a
really ugly midterm election for
democrats and it comes from none other
than the georgia senate race where
former nfl football player herschel
walker who we've covered quite a bit i
mean he's one of the least qualified
people running for senate right now
is leading the incumbent democratic
senator rafael warnock we're going to
look at polling and it would be funny
if it weren't so sad and scary so new
emerson college poll
georgia
walker versus warnock
walker leading 49 to 45 with six percent
undecided now of course there's a three
percent margin of error either way and
six percent undecided so this could go
either way
but these are not good numbers and this
is not the only poll that has it this
way if we look at the real clear
politics page where you could see a
number of the recent polls you see that
walker is leading by an average of 1.6
he's plus four in the emerson poll i
just mentioned walker is plus one in the
recent quinnipiac poll walker is plus
three in the ajc poll
and then back in august of last year in
the democratic leaning poll rafael
warnock was ahead so we don't have that
much polling but none of it looks
particularly good for rafael warnock and
this should genuinely scare us this is
this is one of the most uninformed
people that is running for prominent
office rafael warnock for whatever
you may like or dislike about him
particularly as the incumbent to see him
doing this poorly is very bad remember
that we've talked about recently raphael
i'm sorry uh herschel walker not raphael
warnock said
if evolution is real why are there still
apes remember this brilliant analysis
here that means somebody up there had to
say let there be light that the earth
started and then he had to put someone
there on earth i remember adam was there
remember adam came there then eve came
so somebody had to start it out
so that means it had to be a god because
they didn't just some bomb blew up and
started out and then i tell you
something else i heard and i think about
this
because at one time science said man
came from apes right did it no
i remember that's when you go to it
every time i read or hear that i think
to myself you just didn't read the same
bible i did well this was interesting
though if that is true
why are there still
apes think about it you know now you're
getting too smart for it no no no no
think about this we have an evolution
that is we've gotten so intelligent
that if that is true why are they still
apes right now of course we've talked
about this so many times before well
modern apes and modern humans have a
shared ancestor a really long time ago
and if they're if dogs evolved from
wolves why are there still wolves yeah i
mean it doesn't make any sense but this
guy's winning this guy's winning and
with this is what we're up against and
the voters hear that and they go that's
better than raphael warnock
that's a real problem
that's a real problem here's another one
of herschel walker at a recent trump
rally i think this one was about two
two weeks ago
saying that he's sick of ctr
whoa that's crazy
ctr for this country
people want to ask me all the time while
i'm running i'm sick and tired i'm sick
and tired of them want to
teach ctr in
school
critical race theory can you tell me
what that mean yeah well let's start
getting the acronym correct which is of
course crt this is the guy that's
winning this is the guy that might
replace raphael warnock in the senate so
it's it's very difficult you know in
general
elections aren't isolated and what i
mean by that is
if there's a bunch of incumbents if
there's one incumbent knocked out there
will probably be a bunch of incumbents
knocked out but if i think of a sort of
bellwether representation of the
midterms
if you see
the uh uh incumbent rafael warnock
lose
to a guy who can barely string together
a coherent thought and again if he has a
brain injury from playing football okay
i mean it's not been announced that he
does maybe it's possible but it's it's
it's dubious whether the guy even kind
of has his head on straight
um
if if rafael warnock loses to this guy
it is really going to be a bad sign
for what uh the midterms have in store
and it's probably a bad sign for 2024
it's probably a bad sign for joe biden
in general in his second two years of
his presidency never underestimate the
stupidity of the electorate that's what
we learned from trump in 2016 when i i
was part of it saying
the country wouldn't be so dumb as to
vote republicans wouldn't be so dumb as
to make this guy their dominant nominee
right and they were
and then well the country wouldn't be so
dumb as to make this guy the oh and they
did this is a red alert emergency it
could be disastrous for democrats it
could be disastrous for the country and
those polls look
terrible